COLT MCANLIS: Autoboxing is
one of those weird patterns
in your application.
Sometimes it's not really
a performance problem.
But when it is, wow, does
it chew through your memory
and performance.
My name is Colt McAnlis, and
thanks to the Android Runtime,
you can avoid one of the
largest causes of autoboxing
issues-- HashMap containers.
Now, autoboxing is a process
where the Runtime automatically
converts a primitive type to
its corresponding generic object
type.
But this is bad for two reasons.
Firstly is that
autoboxing will generate
an allocation of
an integer object
for any type of
conversion it uses.
And secondly, these generic
objects are larger in size
than their primitive
counterparts-- 16 bytes
for an integer object rather
than 4 for a primitive,
meaning not only are
they allocating objects,
but those objects are much
larger than they need to be.
Now, typically this
isn't a big problem
for your average computation.
But where it really
gets you is when
dealing with generic
containers like HashMap.
See, when using primitive
types, like int, float,
and Bool, HashMap has to
use the object versions.
So instead of being able
to use a simple 32-bit int,
a HashMap is forced to use
generic integer objects, which,
of course, eat up more memory.
And you need to be careful
here, because any time you
fetch a primitive from
a generic container,
autoboxing happens
there as well.
Now, memory matters to Android.
And to save space,
the Android Runtime
provides a whole family of
generic containers built
specifically to provide the
functionality of the HashMap
but allow you to use primitives
and avoid autoboxing.
Welcome to the
sparse array family.
Sparse arrays are basically like
a ArrayMaps in that they reduce
the overall memory footprint
by using two tightly packed
arrays rather than one
large one for hashing.
But it also comes with some
overhead for fetching objects.
So they're really only
useful for containers
with hundreds of objects rather
than thousands or millions.
The main difference between
sparse arrays and ArrayMaps
is that for sparse arrays,
the key object is always
a defined primitive type
rather than a generic,
allowing you to save memory
and avoid autoboxing.
But in reality, the
differences stop there.
Like ArrayMaps, you
can also iterate over
sparse arrays using indexing
rather than the iterator
pattern, which is
required by HashMaps
and is also significantly slower
and takes up more memory to do.
And also like
ArrayMaps, it's not
wise to use these optimized
sparse array family containers
in every single case.
But there are some
perfect situations
which you should consider.
Number one, situations where you
have a small number of items,
in the hundreds, of lots of
accesses, or the accesses
themselves are infrequent enough
that the overhead for a fetch
isn't noticed.
And number two, situations where
we have containers of maps.
Often it's a map of a map a
map, where the submaps as you
get farther in that
stack tend to have
smaller number of items.
And we also end up
iterating over those submaps
a large number of times.
If your use cases don't fall
into either of those two
buckets, then it
might be best to stick
with the HashMap
class instead of one
of these fancy, awesome
alternatives, which highlights
a very interesting point.
Optimizing performance
is a constant tradeoff
of finding the right container
for the right usage pattern
for the right memory cases.
As someone said, there's
no silver bullet,
which is why you need to check
out the rest of the Android
Performance Patterns content
to get more information
about these types of tradeoffs.
And don't forget to join our
Google+ community as well
to hear war stories
from other developers.
So keep calm, profile your
code, and always remember,
perf matters.